The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at OCW.MIT.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: I want to
focus on the American city,
the contemporary American city,
and the anomalous controversies
which range both
in the profession
and outside the
profession as to what
the condition of the American
contemporary city is,
including everything from
smart growth to new urbanism
to the spread of
[INAUDIBLE] city and so on.
What I'm going to
do is I'm going
to give you a number of inputs.
Some of them you will
disagree with completely.
Some of them you will agree
with depending on your position.
I'd like you to listen to
the comment if you want to,
but I will continue
this on Thursday first
focusing a little more on
decentralization technologies
and climate change.
I want to switch to another
complicated project.
That is the contemporary
American city.
It is, again, a
project about which
there is very little agreement
except like cultural groups who
have vested interests in
believing that one form is
superior to the other.
Cities have always
expanded when they could.
Horizontal land is
cheap to build on
provided you can
get there, provided
you don't have obstacles
like defense, fortresses
or topography or anything else.
Assisi was built on
the slope of a hill
and all of the valley land
could be used for agriculture.
It was a very smart move.
It also provided better
climate high up in the value
and also provided
protection if necessary.
There was water around the city.
These are all logical decisions.
The American city was
relatively contained
until relatively recent times.
I'm just going to go
through and give you
a sketch of the history
of the American city.
Cities have always
expanded horizontally
and is covered by walls natural
barriers or the inability
to communicate over distance.
Policies such as greenbelts or
the exclusion of immigrants,
the 16th and 17th
century attempts
to restrain the growth of
London to exclude the poor
or the apartheid restrictions
on Black immigration
in South Africa have not been
able to maintain themselves
over time.
Recent urban policies
have included
allowing low density
suburban expansion,
building dense public
housing on the periphery,
establishing new towns or
allowing poor immigrants
to squat in minimally
controlled settlements.
American cities was chosen
in the first of these models.
The suburbs in the early
years of the 20th century
were made up of large
lots and made possible
by the invention
of the telephone
and pre-automobile streetcars.
The telephone-- The Socialist
[INAUDIBLE] Telephone
is a book which you should read.
I'll talk about it more
on Thursday's class.
The telephone was introduced
largely for rural populations
to feel less distant from
the rest of the world.
Before World War II less
than half the nation owned
their homes, and less than
half the housing stock
was in single family homes.
After the war, the percentage of
families owning their own homes
jumped from nearly
40% in 1940 to 60%
in 1960 due to a
number of things,
high incomes, the
Federal Highway program
incentives for home ownership
as a stabilizing social force,
Federal Housing Association,
the Veterans Association,
financing, and other factors.
It's this combination of factors
which created and still creates
suburbia.
It's not due to technology.
I'll give you a piece that
I wrote attacking my Manuel
Castells for some of the
stuff that he was advocating.
What has the cell phone done
to the use of public space?
Bill Mitchel, unfortunately,
deceased now was dean here
and wrote books about virtual
technology affecting space
was wrong.
AUDIENCE: Why?
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
what has happened
is that people can communicate
with each other much
better and much faster
and much more frequently,
but it doesn't matter
where they are.
You don't have to go into
the Piazza to call somebody.
It is a form of ubiquity rather
than a form of concentration.
AUDIENCE: But there
are some activities
that before that technology
came or the internet
or data, wireless, there were
activities that were heavily
linked to a place.
They had to be done there, and
now you're not forced to do so.
JULIAN BEINART: Exactly
you're agreeing with me.
I asked you what
the cell phone is
contributed to the increasing
use of public space.
In what form?
I don't understand the answer.
I can call you from here or
I can call you in an office
down there and say let's meet--
let's meet for a drink at
Rockefeller Hotel at 8:00
tonight.
What's different?
Only the speed is different
from me telephoning you
in the morning or
sending you a letter
or sending your
message via pigeon
or whatever form
of communication
we used prior to cell
phones, but the density
of Rockefeller Center
doesn't depend on the advent
of the cell phone.
The cell phone is
more likely to be
a ubiquitous distributor of the
space used than a concentrator.
The same argument
goes for computation.
The number of people in the
United States who work at home
is measured in a number
of different ways.
If you have a
cupboard and you have
a computer in your cupboard,
you work at home whereas in fact
all you do is you
most of the time
play games on your computer
and don't do any work at all,
but you measure this
working at home.
The number of people working
at home is an uneven commodity.
I was in a conference
in Texas where
they were discussing
this phenomenon,
and the real estate people were
advocating all kinds of things.
Let me just finish
this, because I
forgot to go through the
reading list with you-- at least
the handout with you.
Levittown built 150 standard
25 foot by 30 foot cottages
a week, each costing $7,900
requiring with a government
subsidized loan a monthly
payment of $58 for 25 years.
These suburbs attracted
the planned shopping center
and architecturally
unified development
with large amounts
off-street parking.
Suburban growth has broken
the link between city center
and its outskirts.
In 1975, people who
commuted from home
to work in the
suburbs outnumbered
people who commuted
to the central city
were almost 2 to 1.
I wonder if I
should take a break.
Outlying suburbs now called
urban villages or [INAUDIBLE]
cities are more diverse in
land use, have larger houses,
in 2,000, the American house
averaged over 2000 square feet,
twice as large as
it was in 1970.
And they have become
different cultural enterprises
than the post-world
World War II suburb.
I'll go into that a
little while later.
Private automobile
traffic continues
to increase from 1
billion miles in 1970
to 1.5 billion miles in 1987.
And road space
over the same time
decreased from 61 yards
per vehicle to only 31--
to only 39.
While new cars are cleaner,
the condition of the air
is worse in part because
of the increase in car use.
Now these figures are
not updated to 2000.
Laura, I want you to tell me
what the recent figures are.
You are our only
transportation consultant here.
These figures don't
include for the increase
in the purchase of smaller
cars, hybrid cars, and so on.
But recent calculations
of automobile distance
traveled largely
on social trips,
not so much on journey to work
trips, because journey to work
is not very easily
served by transportation.
There's a diagram in
one of the package
I gave you by Robert Cervero,
the author of Transit
Metropolis.
Inner city had this
form, and majority
of the population
worked in one place
or encountered social
activity in one place.
This system, the line
haul, was relatively
elementary be it a street
car, [INAUDIBLE],, or later
on a subway.
The line all depends
on accumulating people
for the space in between
the various line haul,
and we get along good.
The problem, once the generation
of trips starts being this--
to work centers
which now proliferate
outside the centers of city
and form a random pattern.
You get the problem of how to
introduce public transportation
into the distributed
system, which
is much more difficult
than the line-haul system.
We did a project
when I came to MIT
trying to use dual-mode
technology to have
the same vehicle which
operated on the line-haul leave
the line-haul system operate
on the distributor system
and then join the
line-haul system again.
It involved a small vehicle
which had the capacity
to run on the rail and
also to leave a rail
and run on the land.
The distributor system would
be serviced by the telephone.
In other words, you
would call and say,
I want to go to downtown Boston.
And it would say, wait.
In 2.6 minutes time,
you'll be picked up.
And you'll be in Boston
in seven minutes.
This project to
link the distributor
and line-haul system to make
one hasn't been applied anywhere
in the world.
It depends on too
many variables,
and it's too expensive.
But it is technically feasible.
In the meantime, we
have Cervero's diagram,
which tries to make a set of
concentration points outside
linked in various ways, with
small connectors out from this
involving one of the problems
of public transportation.
That's interchange.
What an automobile provides
you is one line to service,
even if it's slow.
You get into a car,
you're in charge.
You can decide where
you want to go.
The problem of moving from
a fast underground line
to a surface bus
line is problematic.
If you have connecting
systems with a train running
on the same level in
a terminus with a bus
system or many-rail system,
you can simply cross.
Some of the European
systems are of this kind.
The chances are that
you will not use the--
but can you imagine a
system in Los Angeles
today where you have to compete
with an automobile on a freeway
by introducing a bus and a
train system as combining.
The one is late.
You miss one, you are to wait
a half an hour for another one.
Public transportation
is available only
as a function of private use.
The cost of maintaining a superb
public transportation system
depends on paying for it
either through subsidy,
which is never enough,
as in the case of Boston.
MBTA is constantly bankrupt.
And one of the things that
congestion pricing has shown
in London is that if you take
a toll of private automobiles
before they enter
into a central space,
you reduce the
number of cars that
are willing to pay
the x number of pounds
that it takes to enter the
space, meaning that you can--
this toll doesn't pay for--
help the public
transportation system enough.
But what does happen is that,
because the roads in this space
are less heavily
traveled by cars,
it means that the bus system
can move much more speedily
and accurately.
I think after x number of
years of the London congestion
pricing system, they've
introduced something
like 100 new buses running on
time and with air conditioning
and all kinds of conveniences.
16% of carbon
emissions have also
been reduced as a result
of congestion pricing.
Congestion pricing is
one of the new artifacts
of the large metropolitan area.
It hasn't been applied
in New York because
of a conflict between the
city and the rural rest
of the state--
a basic conflict in the United
States system of government.
We still depend, in the Senate,
on votes of people in Idaho.
I was just thinking--
you know, we're talking about
cities and having problems.
How long have cities
existed, including
the first permanent
settlements-- say, Jericho,
8000 before Christ?
How many years is that to today?
20,000 years?
What are we now, 2000?
Add it to 8000--
10,000 years.
It took 2.6 million
years for human beings
to develop a brain
large enough to think.
And we're talking
about 12,000 years,
which is nothing in time.
And we're expecting
perfect answers
to communal settlements.
So relax.
[LAUGHTER]
We teach-- I say this
because I'm an architect
and have taught design
studios endlessly.
We tend to idealize
the world that we--
and smooth the world round.
I remember when I worked
for an Image of the City--
it's a research book--
with Kevin Lynch.
Gyorgy Kepes, his
compatriot, asked
me to take a walk down
Washington Street on a busy day
and just note all the
things that I saw.
I made this tabulation of
all the things that I saw--
where the sun was
shining, what noise
there was, what signs
there were, and so on.
And I came up and
presented my work and said,
this is such an unbelievably
confused Washington Street.
I don't know anybody makes sense
of it, because at that time,
all urban design was
Victor Gruen's work,
and how to use modernism
to clean up conflict.
Shopping centers had
unified signpost control,
and here I was trying to say
the real world is infinitely
complex.
And yet, because we have 10 to
the 12 neurons in our brain,
each connecting to
5,000 other sites,
we have the electricity,
electronic system, which
can manage such complexity.
I think it's a message
worth remembering.
Maybe it'll become much clearer.
But I think working as
you do as an urban design
in the midst of a
dialectic of opposites
is an intelligent place to be.
I don't know the resolution
in the world's global economy
between the idea that
what is yours is yours,
and what is yours belongs
partly to a group of people,
as Henry George would
have liked to have argued.
In my life, the debate between
socialism and capitalism
has not abated.
There have been modifications
and conjunctions
and attempts to develop
alternative models.
But essentially, most of you
live in the capitalist world.
You will be struck
between the premise
that you live in
a liberal state.
You are allowed, in
the liberal state,
to choose what system of
communication you wish.
In this case, you will
choose an automobile.
There will be no taxation on
your automobile use of street
except what you pay for gas.
And gasoline taxation for the
use of the roads is minimal.
So what do you do?
I'm just arguing-- you've
got a decentralized city.
You've got a spread city.
I've argued that we need
enormous incentives for people
moving out from the dense center
to horizontal space outside--
sometimes very long distances,
sometimes more compact.
I'll give you a piece
that I wrote on the change
in the American downtown.
There's been a
homeostatic relationship
between the American downtown
and the suburban world.
American downtown is
now increasing in value
and attracting more
and more people.
Only 17% of people in American
downtown are under 20.
So the world is
still one in which
most people in the
American city seeking
to educate their children
will move to suburbia--
often in the direction
of places where
suburban, because of
residential real estate taxes,
are paying for good schools--
rather than staying
in the inner city.
If you stay in the inner
city in the Americans,
and you have enough money,
you pay for private school.
So if you live in the
Back Bay in Boston,
you don't rely on the state
to educate your children.
You pay enormous subsidies
It's all crazy.
It means that the incentives
for living in suburbia
are established very quickly
and very difficult to dislodge
in a free society.
I don't foresee the American
city changing its shape
significantly.
AUDIENCE: I think it's--
I mean, I lived in
DC for two years,
and it's changing already there.
And the other
factor that I don't
think people are
considering enough
is that poverty is
moving to the suburbs
and that's going to create
a really fast flood.
JULIAN BEINART: Well,
one of the arguments
that I would have gotten to
if we can get through all
of this stuff, which is just
stories about the situation,
is that the fetish with
home-ownership in this country
has reduced the capacity
for people to rent.
And rentership allows
much greater mobility
than home-ownership.
Home-ownership creates
conservative investment
in which you don't want
new people to come in.
So you limit the building of new
housing, especially affordable
housing, because
the great virtue
that Herbert Hoover and
Franklin Delano Roosevelt
felt in stabilizing society
through home-ownership
is producing a model whereby
the largest savings you can make
in your life are the profits
between the cost of your house
on purchase and its sale.
And that becomes an enormously
conservative commodity
that you have to maintain.
Do you want a black
family moving next year
a house in Newton?
Well, Newton is a liberal
suburb, so it wouldn't matter.
But in Des Moines, Iowa?
There have been a number pieces
written on the difficulty
now for young families to move
into certain suburban sectors
where the suburban
tax base doesn't
want to spend money
on building schools
for young immigrant families.
So this decentralized, what
Melvin Webber calls the spread
city is not a simple
proposition about having
free space and unlimited
automobile access.
Let me just go through this
sheet of stuff that I gave you.
The first is a controversial
piece called "Prove It--
the Costs and
Benefits of Sprawl."
It's by two University
of Southern California
economists who contend some
of the premises of densifying
the American city.
I'm not going to go
through it in detail.
You can read it.
It's very well-established
as the counterpoint,
the pro-sprawl argument.
After that, just some
newspaper cuttings--
they're now a bit dated.
But it argues that the American
house has doubled in size.
The automobile numbers
have increased.
And whilst the emission
control legislation is worse,
Lester Thurow's next
piece on the next page
is an antidote to electronic
commerce, the spread
of electronic commerce,
arguing that it's being
counted by diversification.
You go to a bookstore now, and
it's a restaurant, as well.
One of the unresolved
pieces of this whole puzzle
is how human beings value
face-to-face contact as opposed
to machine-interposed contact.
Melvin Webber's piece
"Community Without Propinquity,"
which I'll give
you on Thursday, is
one of the classic
pieces of writing,
which argues that,
in the modern city,
you can maintain community
despite distant geography.
And the last piece is a
polemic from the New Urbanists.
Now, given what I said
are some of the problems
of the decentralized city,
let's look at what they offer.
Half of this is untrue.
It's just lies.
But in the traditional of
architecture pamphleteering,
it is common to make
statements which,
if you say them
aggressively enough,
people will believe
them to be true.
Corbusier was a
master at using words.
"By bringing most of the
activities of daily living
into walking distance, everyone,
but especially the elder,
gain independence of movement."
What are we talking about?
The densities that the urbanists
proposed or the developers will
minimize argue
that Americans will
walk seven minutes, at
most, to a destination.
At the densities that you build
in a decentralized American
suburban situation,
admittedly, there
are as many attached
houses in the United States
as there are single houses.
You can probably
develop a market
for a video store
and a 7-Eleven.
So the notion that
you can wander
all over the place purchasing
whatever you want to
is rubbish.
It's nonsense.
It's just pamphleteering.
It should be stopped.
"By reducing the number and
length of automobile trips"--
how do you reduce the number
and length of automobile trips?
If it were easy to do,
we'd all be advocating it.
Well, give me an example.
Were you going to say something?
"By providing
streets and squares,
the pedestrians and
neighbors walking
come to know each other."
There's evidence from
Putnam's work in Bowling Alone
that Americans who
live in apartments
get to know each
other as well as
people living in houses, that
neighborly relationships are
the same independent of
the condition of the block
that you live in.
It's probably true that
the poorer you are,
the more you depend
on your neighbors.
So this is nonsense.
"By providing appropriate
building concentrations
at easy walking
distance from bus stops,
public transit becomes a viable
alternative to the automobile."
We can't finance
the MBTA in Boston
unless we pay enormous
shares of money to--
which probably would be
justified in a decent economy,
but we're not doing it.
So what is the New Urbanist
project for doing this?
AUDIENCE: So I do think that,
if you are walking distance
from a bus or subway,
you don't need a car.
You can [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: But
you need enough people
to do it to pay for
the cost of doing it.
You can't run a public
transportation system
with six people in it.
[LAUGHTER]
It's unfortunately true.
It's as true is eating carrots.
[LAUGHTER]
As true eating carrots
are healthy for you,
which I don't know.
I don't eat carrots.
[LAUGHTER]
But the cost of
public transportation
can only be justified
by seeing it
as a socially important act--
keeping the air cleaner,
having a much greater sense
of belonging to a public, and
so many positive attributes.
But you can't do it
at 10 people per acre.
10 people per acre is
a tenth of an acre lot.
If your family size is three,
it's 30 people per acre.
30 people per acre
generate one trip.
If your school happens
to be on a subway line,
or you're close enough
to walk, give me a break.
Now, you're trying
to say something.
Tell me what you're
trying to say.
AUDIENCE: No, I agree
with the science.
It's completely--
it's not possible.
But what I want to say is
that when there is also
easy way for a car [INAUDIBLE]
or moving by car, which I think
is the case in Boston,
then you can choose.
And it's also-- it's as easy to
move around your car and park
and go on these superhighways
that take you everywhere
really fast.
JULIAN BEINART: Of course.
AUDIENCE: Then it's hard to
decide to take the subway.
But if you're in New York,
where parking is such a hassle,
then of course.
JULIAN BEINART: It's a
hassle in Boston, as well.
AUDIENCE: No, but
it's worse in--
JULIAN BEINART:
In Manhattan, yes.
People per capita
walk in Manhattan
more than they do in
any city in the world,
because of the restrictions
on other forms of access,
although Manhattan is a very
good public transportation
system.
Well, it improved with the
Second Avenue extension.
Why does Manhattan have
a good subway system?
London has the best subway
system in the world.
Why?
AUDIENCE: Because it
was developed first.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes, correct.
In London's case, it
was developed early.
No country in the
world can afford
to build a London
transportation system today.
Its way of predictability saved
the society enormous amount
of money.
The subway system and
the bus system in London
cover almost every--
I think the average distance--
I remember saying it when
we talked about London--
is very small.
Density is one of
the argued solutions.
You put more people into
space, the more of them
will likely be clients for
using public transportation.
And there's nothing that helps
public transportation more
than clients.
It's such an obvious
algorithm that the difficulty
is knowing what to do with it.
And that's where next--
the class on Thursday
is going to ask you
to come up with some solutions.
Let's say the following.
American cities are
going to remain largely
automobile cities.
Rest of the world will
follow to the extent
that it can because gasoline
prices in the United States
are a fraction of gasoline
prices in other parts
of the world and the automobile
highway system has been
subsidized by the state
to an enormous degree
under Eisenhower, starting
with Eisenhower, and so on.
We don't pay for the
roads that we use.
A commuter living in Lexington
passing through Cambridge
every morning past
my house doesn't
pay for the cost of maintaining
their street in Cambridge.
It's free.
We've gotten used to
having free automobile--
but to get agreement
in a country
as large as this
takes a lot of--
can you imagine the opposition?
I don't know what the
senators from Texas
would vote, in favor
of or against taxation
on automobile use,
because we are
using fuel produced in Texas.
And the automobiles use an
enormous amount of fuel.
So does most of the
transportation system
in the United States.
We service most of our
delivery by truck, not by rail.
We have enormous difficulty
in building rail.
You just need to read about
the controversies in California
at the moment trying to link
San Francisco and Sacramento
on the way to Los Angeles.
It passes through Palo
Alto, and there's no place
to put it in Palo Alto.
And land values are
so high in Palo Alto
that you can't do anything
politically about it.
God only knows how it's
going to be resolved.
Anyway, there are
different kinds of suburbs.
The suburbs that originally--
that Levittown was built on had
a daily population of women,
a single car, a station wagon.
A Chevrolet station
wagon's what people had.
They had meatloaf for dinner.
There were no
restaurants and so on.
The Organization Man, the
book by William Whyte,
describes the conditions
in Park Hill--
not Park Hill.
I forget the name of
the suburb of Chicago.
He's in this piece in
your reading list called
"Stressed out in
Suburbia," writes
a description of the suburb,
the new suburb of Naperville,
just further away from Chicago,
where all the restaurants are
ethnic restaurants, all
the stress in the community
is on children
getting higher grades.
So American suburbs
have grown in wealth.
Houses are given French names.
The neighborhoods are all
given foreign names and so on.
It's quite amusing.
Let me just pick up
some other things.
Robert Putnam from
Harvard has written
a book called
Bowling Alone, which
causes a big surge of
interest in social science.
He claims that what has
happened in the United States--
and he's not blaming
suburbia for it--
is that there's been a much--
strong tendency towards
individualism as
opposed to belonging to
a community or sharing.
He quotes endlessly.
Religious affiliation
has dropped.
The United States has more
houses of worship per capita
than any other nation on Earth.
There's been a modest decline
in all church-related groups
over the past 20 years.
Union membership
has been falling
for nearly four decades.
The Parent Teacher
Association has become--
which has always been
an important form
of civic engagement
in 20th century
America, has declined
from 12 million in 1964
to barely 5 million in 1982.
Volunteering for traditional
women's groups, the League
of Women Voters, the
Red Cross, Boy Scouts,
all have dropped in attendance.
He counters that by
talking about groups
that have increased in size.
I didn't know this, but
the American Association
of Retired Persons, AARP,
has grown exponentially,
from 400,000 card-carrying
members in 1960 to 33 million
in 1993, becoming, after
the Catholic Church,
the largest private
organization in the world.
When he asked in
his social survey
in 1974, "How often do
you spend a social evening
with a neighbor?"
the proportion of Americans who
socialized with their neighbors
more than once a
year has slowly but
steadily declined over the past
to two decades from 72% to 61%,
whereas friends who do not
live in your neighborhood
appears to be on the increase.
Oh, we have some time.
I looked at the wrong
thing on my watch.
The use of the automobile,
in metropolitan terms,
is interesting in
another respect.
[DOOR OPENS]
What's--
AUDIENCE: It's 2 o'clock.
JULIAN BEINART:
Oh, it's 2 o'clock.
I'm sorry.
I've got a dull watch.
[LAUGHTER]
I'll continue with some
more evidence for you
to put into your
mincing machine.
But I expect some feedback
as to where you stand.
In the end, maybe it's simply
where you stand that matters.
Many of you architects will
favor densification of the city
despite any notion
of how it can be
achieved in a liberal society.
Maybe an American city is
just like American democracy--
slow and full of pitfalls,
not doing anything about gun
control when it's
obvious that it should,
And yet it's survived.